when a viral outbreak or dangerous
bacteria threatens human life
the CDC's disease detectives are often
on the front lines they go in prepared
for anything because the diseases they
study like Ebola hantavirus Marburg
monkey pox and anthrax are some of the
deadliest on earth my name is Brian
Amman I'm a disease ecologist with Viral
special pathogens branch here is the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention my job essentially is to go
out into areas where an outbreak has
occurred capture animals and test these
animals for ZOA notic viruses
specifically for the ones that have
caused the outbreak probably the most
notable are Ebola and Marburg hantavirus
and are some of the rain of viruses that
occur here in the United States now I'm
gonna tell you about some of the stuff
that I take out into the field this is a
harp trap it's called a harp trap
because it looks like a harp you can see
these fishing this fishing line attached
to the top and the bottom but these are
designed to catch bats and you can put
them in front of caves or in flyaways
and the bats will come and they'll hit
these lines and they'll get caught in
between here and it kind of messes with
their flight and they sort of tumble
down in to this catch bag down here
where you can reach in and pull them out
we catch bats because we test them for
diseases we know they carry a variety of
diseases some of which cause very severe
illnesses in humans I have here a little
GPS tracker this tracker is designed to
go on to the back of a bat and what this
will do is this will tell us where the
bat goes at night now the reason we're
doing this is because we think that the
bats that have Marburg virus are going
out and they're going into farmers
cultivated fruit crops they like mangoes
they like bananas they'll give it a
little bite if they don't like it they
drop it on the ground and the next day
or the next morning some child or some
family pet comes along and eats that
fruit and becomes infected with Marburg
virus it could very easily start the
next outbreak so by knowing where these
bats go at nighttime we can actually
essentially build a risk map we can get
the message out that hey don't pick
fruit up off the ground if it's been bit
and leave it alone these are our powered
air respirator filters we like these
because instead of wearing caving helmet
with the half or a full face face yield
we can use these but this is a helmet
it's very industrial if you bang your
head you're not going to fill it it's
extremely comfortable but you just
simply strap this on to your waist put
that on your head and you're good to go
this bag right here you can see it's
kind of a backpack and it's designed
actually to be a scuba diving bag now
one of the first things that go on our
snake chaps because when you're out
walking around in the jungle and I've
done this many times you you tend to
step closer or almost on a lot of
venomous snakes and these snake chaps or
Kevlar lines so that if anything bites
the outside of this they won't go
through and penetrate your pants and
then your leg these are the snake
gaiters that we wear when we're hiking
around in the jungle they're a lot
shorter than the cave snake chaps that
we wear but these are all much more
comfortable to walk around in steamy hot
jungles with that they're pretty simple
to put on the the snake chaps that we
wear in the cave will actually extend
all the way up past your hip because
there's a good potential of walking past
a rock ledge and having the snake come
out and give you a strike in your leg
and this is a half face respirator and
the reason we use these instead of
Packers out of the net is the poppers
can tend to be pretty heavy and if
you're walking several kilometres
between each net that can deck entire
area tire you out especially in the heat
and the humidity of the rainforests the
way you put these on you simply put it
over your face like this and then hook
it up and that provides a good seal and
when you couple that with the face
shield now you're talking practically
the same kind of protection you would
get out of a chopper one of the most
important pieces of our personal
protective equipment are these gloves
they're turtle skin New York City
Department of Corrections gloves they
have a Kevlar lining and this gives us
still some dexterity to take bats out of
gnats or to take them out of the case
but their bite resistant so the bats can
bite you with these gloves on and not go
through now some of the things that we
put in here that I don't have with me
are probably the most important is a
bottle spray bottle filled with micro
chem
and micro cam is a viral Seidel
detergent that we use as a disinfectant
every time we take a bat out of the net
we will spray ourselves off starting
with our hands we go all the way up our
arms we spray the face shield everything
including the gown all the way down to
our boots just on the off chance that if
we did get something on us and we didn't
notice it and it potentially has virus
in it that we hit it with this
disinfectant and it kills any kind of
virus so that we don't take it back to
the vehicles we don't accidentally touch
it with our hands and put it in our
mouth so everything gets sprayed off
each and every time I always take my own
towel in the more rural areas towels are
typically washed and then hung over
bushes to dry and during this drying
process there's a little fly called a
tumbu fly or a mango fly that lays its
eggs on the wet cloth and once you put
that egg on your body it hatches and
burrows into your skin
now if the towels aren't ironed then the
egg isn't destroyed and it stays on the
towel until you use it on your body to
dry off so I always take my own towels
because I don't trust that people iron
their towels last but not least I always
take this journal and I essentially
write notes and letters home to my sons
when I'm out there I've got several
years of of outbreak responses and field
research all written down in here for my
boys to read when they're old enough to
understand and appreciate what's been
going on these past years when I've been
leaving for three and four weeks at a
time we don't always have reliable
cellular service we don't have email
contact and a lot of times it can be
days before I get to speak with them and
by me writing to them it makes me feel
like I'm talking to them and it helps me
deal with some of the homesickness that
I experienced when I leave my boys
behind what I hope that they get out of
it is a sense of adventure and knowing
that their dad was at least out there
trying to do something good for somebody
somewhere this is some of the equipment
that I use out in the field
it helps me complete my work and it
helps me complete it safely
by I'm Ryan Wallace and I'm a veterinary
Abedini ologist with the US Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention and this
is what I bring with me when I go into
the field when I go out we're often
called on responses to aggressive
potentially rabid animals and walk long
distances to try to find them and the
people they've bitten and so we have to
be able to carry everything with us on
our backs to make sure we can properly
assess those animals and the people that
have been rabies is a virus it's the
deadliest disease in the world about a
99.9 percent fatality rates if you were
to get it about fifty nine thousand
people every year do die from rabies
most of the animals that bite people
don't have rabies luckily here in the
United States rabies has been eliminated
from our dog population but we do still
have to deal with it in numerous
wildlife species we sit in an office and
wait for somebody to call us and say
there is a rabid animal in their
neighborhood at that point we have to
have everything ready to go that we
would possibly need to keep ourselves
safe capture that animal assess it for
rabies and then be able to provide
recommendations to the person who's
exposed so we'll start with the backpack
we have a throw net like I said these
rabid dogs do not like to sit still
sometimes they're running away from us
sometimes they're running towards us
this net can be useful to try to
restrain that animal so we can come up
and give it a better assessment we're
out doing vaccinations and we vaccinated
an animal and we need to give it a mark
so that we don't vaccinate it again
tomorrow
well sometimes use the squirt gun just
to give it a little paint on the side
that way we know this animal isn't
vaccinated if we do unfortunately have
to euthanize or sedate an animal these
are our medications our needles and our
syringes dogs bite for all sorts of
reasons it's actually rarely due to
rabies it's because we got too close to
it or we antagonized it over food
improver those instances we can provide
a chain to the owner and ask them to
keep the dog chained up for 10 days and
if that animals still healthy after 10
days that means it didn't have rabies
that is what's in my backpack when we go
out when we train staff we usually start
with a dummy our dummy today is Seamus
I'm gonna show you on Sheamus how we use
a few pieces of equipment this is the
Catchpole easiest way to do it is to
just put in front of the animal with a
little bit of food they'll put their
head in front of it and then you just
slip it over slip it over like this and
then lightly close it if Sheamus was
really aggressive our goal is to get her
in a prone position and sedated as soon
as possible in that case we're gonna put
her down to the ground and one of our
other veterinarians will come up and
give an injection that'll put her to
sleep and then we can safely assess her
and the whole situation these are
absolutely critical to any rabies
investigation these are bite proof
gloves I have had dogs hanging off of my
hand biting me up in the air they can't
get through these if we can't get that
close to the dog maybe it's running away
or it's very aggressive and we don't
feel comfortable approaching it we can
use a blowgun
here's our blowgun the dart gets loaded
into here and then you can shoot it out
at this end from a safe distance so
normally would be about 15 to 20 feet
away you would aim at the dog and that
dart would have hit the dog right into
the muscle injecting the medication and
after a few minutes we can come up and
safely assess that animal try to decide
if it has rabies or not this equipment
keeps me safe keeps the animals safe it
allows us to take rabid animals out of
the communities thereby keeping all the
people safe as well my name is Sarah
guardo and I am a disease detective with
the division of high consequence
pathogens and pathology a disease
detective is someone that spends their
time trying to track down different
types of diseases so what we're looking
for is patterns and behavior and that
could be related to food or water or
even interaction with animals a lot of
the work that we do requires gear so if
you forget your gear for work then you
will not be able to complete the task so
now I'm going to show you a typical
trunk that we use to transport field
supplies and different types of gear we
can have up to 15 trunks in a single
trip boots classic tent always helpful
to bring with you because sometimes
you're not sure where you're gonna be
sleeping this is really cool this is a
a UV based water filter you can take off
the cover here make sure it's got its
batteries in it and you put it in dirty
water and you push the button and a lamp
comes on with UV light and the UV light
will actually kill any kind of viruses
or bacteria or protozoa
that are in the water so this is really
neat we also bring blood collection
supplies tourniquets they're very
helpful for blood collection gloves that
are you know used for a variety of
different purposes so this is a cold box
we use this in the field to transport
specimens and the way it works is that
you would actually have to freeze the
entire box for a certain period of time
for several hours and then once you're
in the field you place the specimens in
here and it's actually kept cold for up
to 72 hours which is really cool I also
haven't here five different types of
phone including a personal phone a CDC
work phone
another type of CDC phone which tends to
get better reception I also have a local
phone and lastly we have a satellite
phone and this thing is pretty cool we
also have the CDC medical kit the
medications you might find in here
include antibiotics like flagyl or cipro
they're also anti malarial pills in here
that you have to take once a day iodine
for sterilizing any kind of open wound
and water purification tablets so there
are different types of personal
protective equipment or PPE
for different situations so it depends
on what activities you're doing one
example here is a Tyvek suit that I
brought
make sure you got it all the way around
you and they need you want to zip it up
also have a face shield just helpful to
make sure that nothing is splashing in
your face and then of course gloves and
you're ready to get to work I'm Clint
Morgan I'm a biologist with the pox
virus and rabies branch our fieldwork
looks a little different than some
epidemiology fieldwork we're actually
going and trapping animals and sampling
them with hopes that they may have some
of these viruses that we're looking for
so monkey pox is a virus that's very
closely related to smallpox it can kill
up to ten percent of people who are
infected with it it was first recognized
in the in the 50s when it infected some
monkeys so then they named it monkey pox
because it was first isolated from these
these monkeys the viruses usually comes
from rodents and so we need certain
traps to catch these animals to test
them for the virus and relay that
information back to epidemiologists who
deal with the outbreak response here
this is a cage style live trap me open
it up real quick and in Africa this is
good for squirrels or Gambian pouched
rats which are the animals that we think
are the primary carriers of monkey pox
virus you open up the the front this
little part here is called the trail
comes up and we put the bait in the back
hopefully the animal will walk in
wanting to get the bait step on this the
door and the front will close and you
have caught your animal and here we have
these smaller live traps and go in just
pull one out for now alright and this is
this kind of trap is perfect for smaller
animals like small rodents and shrews
they just run in the front boom and
they're captured this is rolled oats and
peanut butter when combined is a really
good really good mixture to attract most
most rodents in any part of the world
also bird seed and even some vanilla
extract
works well for rodents in the tropics
and so we actually use a machete a lot
to cut through the forest undergrowth
and stuff where we're set trying to set
up the traps another really important
item for biosafety and protecting
yourself is a papper which stands for
powered air purifying respirator so what
it does it sucks in the air through this
filter in the front it'll pump it up
through this hose and into the mask
which which you'll be wearing and so
this hood will just go over your head
like so this way I'm breathing in the
air that's being filtered this paper is
very important if there's some kind of
biological contaminant in the area or
you're doing direct handling of infected
samples or animals take this off and in
this bag we just have some little things
that we use when we're processing the
animals this is a spring scale so when
we need to take a weight of the animal
we just use this little alligator clip
clip on to it and it gives us a weight
and some alcohol pads just some general
items that we use for sample processing
and once we get all the samples we need
we need to store them and that's where
this comes in this is a liquid nitrogen
tank it's a referred to as a dry shipper
we charge this with liquid nitrogen a
few days in advance before we go into
the field and it's good for about two
weeks afterwards let me pull this top
off and this is a nitrogen gas coming
out we actually use pantyhose of all
things because it can go down into
liquid nitrogen and it's easily
retrievable afterwards just put our
tubes and just drop it in that way the
samples are very cold and this little
tab hangs out so once you collect blood
from an animal you set those tubes into
this mini centrifuge and that will
separate out the serum which is a
component of the blood which will tell
you whether it has been exposed to
monkey pox or not and what we're looking
for is the
presence of antibodies and some of the
places we go don't have electricity and
so a portable generator like this or
something similar is very important to
power the items that we have so that's
the gear that we use we need every
single part of it to accomplish our goal
of going on to the field capturing the
animals bringing those samples back to
the lab getting some more information
about this virus and ultimately save
lives